[Music]
breaking news this Friday night David
Johnston steps down the special Rapport
tour into foreign interference bows to
pressure and resigns
dueling demonstrations over lgbtq2 plus
rights
[Applause]
the heated confrontations and arrests
outside some Ottawa schools and New
Brunswick's revised policy for students
causes and uproar
and the first felony indictment against
a former U.S president I'm an innocent
man the 37 charges Donald Trump has been
hit with
global national with para Nasser good
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin tonight with breaking news out of
Ottawa David Johnston the former
Governor General and Special Report tour
on foreign interference has resigned for
weeks now he's faced numerous calls from
opposition parties to step down over his
recommendation to not hold a public
inquiry into allegations of Chinese
efforts to influence Canadian elections
our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson joins us now Mercedes what do
we know so far
well pharah just on Tuesday David
Johnston was vowing to carry out his
duties as the independent special
Rockport tour despite that political and
public pressure on him a very different
tone tonight in a letter addressed to
prime minister Justin Trudeau which we
have right here with us and we're going
to share with you and our viewers David
Johnston says that he has to step aside
because well he took the job he says to
help build trust in our Democratic
institutions quote I have concluded that
given the highly partisan atmosphere
around my appointment and work my
leadership has had the opposite effect
and he is therefore tendering his
resignation he goes on pharah to say
that foreign interference is a very
significant problem in Canada and it
needs to be looked into however he has
not changed his mind in saying that he
does not believe a public inquiry is the
answer he says that he thinks there
should be public hearings but an inquiry
still would not get to the bottom of
this because it would deal with highly
classified information he also ends with
a piece of advice to the Prime Minister
saying I encourage you to point a
respected person to do this job with
National Security experience to complete
the work I recommended in my first
report ideally you would consult with
the opposition parties to identify
suitable candidates and that really gets
Farah to the pressure that has been on
him from the NDP and the conservatives
both of whom have demanded a public
inquiry something he was resistant to
tonight NDP leader jugmeet Singh Is
tweeting that David Johnston has done
the right thing and it's time for a
public inquiry the conservatives also
saying time for a public inquiry we've
been hearing from Aaron O'Toole as well
as from the conservative ethics critics
still waiting to hear from Pierre poliov
tonight but obviously they want that to
go forward we also have a a response
from the government that I just briefly
want to read to you as well from Daniel
LeBlanc the minister in charge of this
file he thanks David Johnston for his
service and says the partisan attacks
levied by the conservative party against
the former Governor General were
unwarranted and unacceptable so now this
is laid at the feet of prime minister
Justin Trudeau to decide what he does
next we'll be watching Mercedes
Stevenson with our breaking news out of
Ottawa thank you Mercedes
a week into pride month 2023 the clock
seems to be ticking backward it wasn't
that long ago that the fear and
vulnerability felt for Generations in
the lgbtq2 plus Community seemed to
slowly be easing yet tonight we have
another sobering reminder of the hate
and open aggression that still very much
exists
this afternoon outside a school in
Ottawa tensions flared as hundreds of
counter-protesters standing in
solidarity with
lgbtq2 plus people faced off with
anti-trans demonstrators the flash point
of their anger children and their gender
rights and identity
now this is just the latest in a growing
string of hostile standoffs throughout
this country tariya isri reports
children of anti-trans demonstrators
trampled on Pride Flags in front of a
school
in a rally that's a microcosm for the
rising hostility facing the queer
community in Canada
in a far-right event organized outside
three schools
[Applause]
[Music]
counter protesters outnumbered
anti-trans demonstrators police tried to
keep both sides apart you know we have
brought support here and we're basically
trying to push back against the you know
transphobic message that uh an hateful
message that message is being Amplified
outside libraries and schools across the
country as the number of anti-trans
protests spike in Canada and anti-trans
bills passed throughout North America I
am disappointed to see that anti-trans
protesters have decided to make their
grievances heard in front of schools as
opposed to Queen's Park or Parliament
where protests are perhaps better Suited
the demonstration comes right at the
start of pride month and at a time of
growing hostility towards the queer
Community particularly trans people
the Toronto area also turned hostile
this week students walked out of school
after the York Region Catholic School
Board voted against raising the pride
flag an anti-trans activist from BC
organized the rally in Ottawa against
what he calls gender ideology why are we
doing telling kids that boys and girls
aren't real Chris Elston is behind
similar events across the country I'm
pro pro free speech
um
I think everyone deserves to have their
voices heard but people
who's the message
the hospital that's another pretty
straightforward thing you know I I have
zero tolerance for that ridiculousness
and in the face of
interior is Global News Ottawa
and the same issue is causing division
in the New Brunswick government Premier
Blaine Higgs is defending changes made
to the province's policy on sexual
orientation and gender identity in
schools he says the changes are designed
to protect lgbtq2 plus students and take
a strong position for families but he's
now facing a Revolt within government
ranks and as Eric Sorensen reports he
might even be willing to call an
election over it
it's called policy 713 passed three
years ago by the New Brunswick
government to create an inclusive
environment around gender identity for
lgbtq2 plus students the revised policy
will come into effect on July 1st but
changes announced by the education
Minister require among other things
parental consent for children under 16
who want to identify by a different name
and pronoun we do not exclude parents in
their child's life Premier Blaine Higgs
defended the changes Thursday but it
sparked a backlash including from the
Prime Minister trans kids in New
Brunswick are being told they don't have
the right to be their true selves that
they need to ask permission will trans
kids need to feel safe not targeted by
politicians
it's unfortunate the Prime Minister will
wouldn't look at the big picture and
understand that families parents play a
role in the children's upbringing but
Higgs also faces blowback from his own
caucus eight mlas including six cabinet
ministers boycotted Thursdays sitting in
the legislature issuing a statement
expressing our extreme disappointment in
a lack of process and transparency one
Minister spoke about it recently the
people that have fought so long for
inclusivity feel like they're having
something taken away so we have to be
able to put ourselves in those shoes
conservative politicians in the U.S have
seized on the issue Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis is embroiled in a fight with
Disney and has passed several
anti-lgbtq2 plus laws we're not doing
the pronoun Olympics in Florida it's not
happening here in Toronto conservative
leader Pierre poliev sidestepped when
asked his view of the New Brunswick
policy changes I'll let provinces make
decisions about the education system
advocates for the original policy worry
that changes will only encourage bullies
to harass kids who identify differently
we've come such a long way and what
Blaine Higgs is doing is pulling us back
this is not going to end well this is
going to hurt children Higgs is not
backing down in what seemed to be a
message to his own caucus to toe the
line he suggested he might call an
election on this would I do that it's
not without the realm of possibility
Eric Sorensen Global News
the Toronto Blue Jays are moving on from
pitcher Anthony bass after he made
headlines last week for sharing
anti-lgbtq2 plus posts on social media
now this is quite the turnaround as bass
was set to help the team kick off Pride
weekend celebrations tonight at the
Rogers Center but as Mike drolets for
many the controversial pitchers symbolic
gesture was too little too late for an
organization that Prides itself on
inclusion
on the field the Toronto Blue Jays are
on a winning streak off it they're in
turmoil we definitely don't want anyone
feeling any hurt
um you know we're we're focused on the
environment we care about this community
we care about our fans and I I deeply
regret if people do feel that way
certainly was not Our intention pitcher
Anthony bass who had posted his support
for a homophobic video on social media
was supposed to catch the ceremonial
first pitch Friday for the start of the
team's celebration of Pride weekend
until the Jays dumped him hours before
the game it does send a little bit of a
mixed message in my opinion he's going
to be center stage and now he's going to
be booted off stage that's kind of like
what what I hear it was only a day ago
Blue Jays GM Ross Atkins called bass
more enlightened more aware of the hurt
he'd caused here we are after fan outcry
a 180 and bass has no future in Toronto
there's a myriad of variables
performance is is usually the driving
one and performance was a large aspect
of this decision
distraction was a small part of it and
you know something that we had to factor
in it's been a turbulent 10 days since
bass promoted and shared a video
instructing Christians to boycott Bud
Light and target for supporting lgbtq
plus initiatives this is evil this is
demonic we won't stand for it bass gave
a Kurt apology met with pride leaders to
discuss his beliefs and then try the
apology again Thursday only this time he
threw a little more spin on it claiming
he doesn't find it offensive I do not
that's why I posted it originally when I
looked back at it I could see how people
can view it that way
and that's why I I was apologetic
baseball writer RJ McDaniel says the
Jays had no choice other than perhaps
cutting bass sooner I think that they
felt that they needed to cut their
losses immediately without having the
distraction spy several even more out of
control but that's being on the field
for the Pride Celebration now a weekend
intended to be all about inclusivity in
sport is focused on a guy who won't be
there unless he buys a ticket microwave
Global News Toronto
Canada's Wildfire season is already off
to a roaring start coming up the climate
connection and its devastating impacts
[Music]
if there was any glimmer of hope that
British Columbia would be spared a
devastating Wildfire season
that has disappeared this week fire
officials warned that hot dry weather
throughout the month of May have made
conditions challenging and early
snowpack melt could add to the troubles
as Nita garcha reports these scenarios
are being mimicked all across western
Canada
oh
this aggressive and extreme fire
activity in northeastern BC forced the
evacuation of a community of nearly 2500
people Thursday
evacuees like Jennifer slack tried to
explain what's happening to her young
son this morning he asked if our house
is there if it was burned and I told him
I didn't know it was a bit of
pandemonium there for a bit that the
fuel pumps and places like that in the
grocery stores on Vancouver Island an
out-of-control Wildfire east of Port
Alberni shut down the only Highway
connecting the community with the rest
of BC Manitoba is bracing for heavy
lightning generating thunderstorms as
Alberta sees more evacuation orders
there's no clear or single answer as to
what's causing these fires but a forest
management expert here in BC says a
clear sign of the bigger picture issues
at play is the Tinder dry conditions in
this Vancouver Park well we're standing
in a temperate rainforest
rainforest it doesn't look like a
rainforest right now I would say that
climate change is undoubtedly a factor
affecting these fires he says that's
because of the predicted changes in
climate from drought in the East to
warmer temperatures earlier in the west
we have fires right the way across
Canada in nine provinces two territories
and that's unprecedented we asked
experts across the country and in the
U.S about the connection between climate
change and Canada's wildfires global
warming has a direct and obvious effect
on the risk by raising temperature which
will dry out vegetation more quickly and
more completely we're also seeing a
number of fires being caused by
lightning climate change is projected to
increase the number of lightning
ignitions as atmospheric temperature
warms there have been other Springs that
have been dry and warm but not across
the entire country better Forest
management techniques like proactively
removing highly flammable materials can
help
this is all drying out and it becomes
incredibly flammable and you can see how
easy it's broken especially as those
like Alberta's Premier continue
downplaying the connection between
climate change and wildfires which
experts say is obvious need to garcha
Global News Vancouver
and over on the U.S east Coast where
smoke from Ontario and Quebec's
wildfires has choked several cities like
New York and Washington DC the air
quality is now improving Quebec's
Wildfire situation still isn't great but
it has stabilized and what's really
needed is rain as Mike Armstrong reports
that could still be days away
thank you
it may be early in the Wildfire season
but this is already for Quebec
unhistorically rough year
707 thousand hectares have been burned
that's more than four times the area
burned in the last 10 years combined
that was the Sprint
Quebec's firefighting agency sub firm
now says the Sprint is over but the
marathon phase is starting the situation
on the ground has at least been stable
and reinforcements have given Crews a
second win new firefighters have arrived
from New Brunswick and France they'll
boost the 800 already working and more
are on the way firefighters from the
United States Portugal and Spain around
300 of them on the next June the 12th
now the fires are forced the evacuation
of several towns people were told to
leave nor metal on the weekend and a few
days later the Flames came within 500
meters of the town
but the evacuations are dragging on
Saturday will make it a full week since
cleared out the mayor says he knows
people want to go home but says the
weather has to cooperate there was some
rain overnight but after three dry weeks
the barely two millimeters they got
isn't enough
it's more than nothing the mayor says
but it's not much
now evacuees are being told to register
with the province there will be
compensation a flat fifteen hundred
dollars per person checks will start
going out next week now there may be
some small amounts of rain this weekend
but that system could also bring
lightning something that starts fires
winds shouldn't be a problem for the
next few days but the only real rain in
the region likely won't be until Tuesday
Mike Armstrong Global News
indictment unsealed ahead the dozens of
federal charges against former U.S
president Donald Trump
former U.S president Donald Trump is
facing his most serious legal troubles
yet he's now the first former
commander-in-chief to be charged with
federal crimes and as Jackson prosco
explains the charges are related to
National Security and how Trump
allegedly mishandled classified
information
the unsealed indictment offers a
stunning look at the allegations against
the former president including images of
America's deepest Secrets carelessly
stored in a ballroom a bathroom and a
shower at Donald Trump's Mar-A-Lago
estate are laws that protect National
Defense information are critical to the
Safety and Security of the United States
and they must be enforced special
counsel Jack Smith is unequivocal that
Trump was not allowed to possess top
secret and classified documents after he
ceased being president he's now charged
with 37 counts including conspiracy
making false statements and a staggering
31 counts of willful retention of
National Defense information for keeping
documents concerning America's nuclear
weapons foreign military capabilities
and top secret White House briefings we
have one set of laws in this country and
they apply to everyone it's called
election interference they're trying to
destroy a reputation so they can win an
election Trump's fiery Thursday night
offensive was quickly overshadowed there
are allegations he twice showed
classified documents to people who were
not authorized to see them there is an
audio recording of at least one instance
these are very serious charges and
they're also the kind of charges that
are likely to be particularly easy to
prove the conspiracy charges allege
Trump and his aide Walt NADA moved
documents so they would not be found by
investigators even after the Department
of Justice issued a subpoena for their
return there are multiple text messages
phone calls and conversations including
evidence provided by Trump's own lawyer
that Trump asked his legal team to lie
this is information that could cause
extraordinary harm to the United States
uh government and to our national
security if it's disclosed publicly it's
important to remember that it was a
grand jury made up of ordinary citizens
that voted to indict Trump based on the
evidence if he is ultimately convicted
he could face up to 100 years in prison
his first court appearance is set for
Tuesday in Miami
pharah
Jackson prosco thank you
[Music]
happy homecoming next the long-awaited
return for some Nova Scotia fire
evacuees
[Music]
today nearly two weeks after some of the
worst wildfires Nova scotians have ever
seen some were finally allowed back home
Megan King has a first-hand look at
their return
stocking up hoping to head home this
parking lot acting as a waiting area for
evacuees like Greg Hammond who anxiously
waited to hear if he'd be cleared to
return to his neighborhood I took the
day off work
to come out here and you know make sure
I'm one of the little ducklings in a row
that gets back in
an emergency alert just after 1 pm
Friday allowed just that
cars streamed along Hammonds Plains Road
as barriers were moved and families
headed home 13 days I
I was nervous I was a lot of anxiety we
came back Monday for meds and it gave me
and all my family really hope getting
everything out of the freezers and stuff
we want to freeze everything back up and
get rid of it all because we don't know
what we're walking into so we just don't
have answers yet so but we have home
we're grateful so many don't and yeah
it's just it's devastating everybody's
lucky
lost homes but you know what no lives
yay the house is still here Hammond's
return left him ecstatic as you see
behind me my house is intact I've been
inside uh smells a little bit of smoke
that's okay the roof had a little bit of
damage with the water bombers coming
over make sure the area was saturated
that's cool relief for many and
recognition that's not the case for
everyone wow it's
it's a little bit of a
a tearful moment because I know what
other people have lost and what I was
fortunate enough to still have Megan
King Global News upper 10 Talon Nova
Scotia
and that's it for global national on
this Friday night I'm Farah Nasser on
behalf of our whole team here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us
tonight's your Canada is this Ruddy Duck
in Saskatoon until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
foreign
[Music]